c'est un procès fleuve mais nécessaire
un procès qui franchie cet automne que
l'étape la plus douloureuse pour les
familles des victimes du vol est magique
certains tenaient à venir en personne au
tribunal
l'autre n'avait pas la force ils ont
exprimé de loin
cette douleur qu'ils ont en commun un
deuil insurmontable même sept ans plus
tard
son fils était le seul canadien à bord
du vol l'image du set de la malaise
général andriana avait 24 ans étudiant
en médecine amoureux
il a péri avec sa copine olga dans ce
champ tournesol en ukraine où duquel le
boeing a été abattu sauvagement par un
missile book qu'il enquête nous le dira
a été fourni par l'armée russe dans
cette entrevue en 2016 les parents
d'anne dray et venait de récupérer ses
effets personnels dont le t-shirt qu'il
portait dans l'avion
aujourd'hui dans son témoignage son père
n'avait qu'une seule requête obtenir
justice
justice qui semble encore inatteignable
explique l'avocat de la famille
les quatre accusés brille par leur
absence au procès la russie refuse de
les extrader tous sont des hauts gradés
du mouvement séparatiste pro russe qui
aurait selon l'anc est obtenue déployer
le missile en territoires occupés dans
l'est de l'ukraine
cette femme qui a témoigné depuis
l'australie les interpeller
car pour les familles des deux cent
quatre-vingt dix-huit victimes la
responsabilité du kremlin dans cette
tape sur deux tragédies est un des miens
reste que le kremlin a toujours refusé
de collaborer à l'enquêté
eni à ce jour toute implication
mais pour ce père inconsolable venir
témoigner était un devoir
et un
dernier acte d'amour et de respect pour
son fils ici tu as marre altérer ce que
radio-canada